Welcome to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Here at Hidden Brain, we are hard at work on new episodes for later the summer and fall. So this week, we're going to bring you a story from our archives. It aired first on the public radio show This American Life, in an episode titled The Heart Once What It Once. This story is slightly longer than our usual episode, and it's best heard in a single sitting. So we're going to give it to you without any interruptions. Okay, this is the tale of a con that unfolded very slowly over two decades.
欢迎收听《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在《隐藏大脑》，我们正全力制作今年夏末秋初的新节目。所以本周，我们将为您带来一份来自我们档案馆的故事。它最初在公共广播节目《This American Life》中播出，单集标题为《曾经的心》。这个故事比我们通常的节目稍长，最适合一口气听完。因此，我们将不作任何插播，直接为您呈现。好的，这是一个历时二十年徐徐展开的骗局的故事。
What fascinates me about the story is that when the con was finally exposed, many of the victims were heartbroken. They wanted it to go on. They wanted to keep believing. So here's how the con worked. Guys around the country signed up for a penpal service. It would put them in touch with women they could be friend and car is part with. And then they'd start to receive letters.
这个故事最让我着迷的是，当骗局最终被揭穿时，许多受害者心碎不已。他们希望骗局能继续下去。他们想继续相信下去。所以，这个骗局是这样运作的。全国各地的男士们注册了一项笔友服务。它能让他们与可以与之交友并分担爱意的人取得联系。然后，他们就会开始收到信件。
They come from Hillsdale, Illinois, and some of them are white, pink, green. Jesse is a sweet, soft-spoken man with thick plastic aviator glasses. He started receiving the letters in 1985 when he was in his 30s. Back then, he was overweight. He'd never had a serious girlfriend, always lived with his parents. After his mother died, he spent most of his time taking care of his sick dad Then he was overweight. He'd never had a serious girlfriend, always lived with his parents. After his mother died, he spent most of his time taking care of his sick dad and working
它们来自伊利诺伊州希尔斯代尔，其中一些是白色、粉色、绿色的。杰西是一个温和、轻声细语的男人，戴着厚厚的塑料飞行员眼镜。他于1985年30多岁时开始收到这些信件。当时，他体重超标。他从来没有过正经女朋友，一直和父母住在一起。母亲去世后，他大部分时间都在照顾生病的父亲——然后他体重超标。他从来没有过正经女朋友，一直和父母住在一起。母亲去世后，他大部分时间都在照顾生病的父亲并工作。
at his family's restaurant. Jesse's favorite letters came from a woman named Pamela. I, yes, I usually took it at the end of the day when I got him in the mail, went into my room, and laid on my bed, and just sat there and read them. Dear Jesse, deep down you know as well as I do that you could be a lot better off than you are if you only had someone on your side. Someone who would help you encourage you work with you and stick with you even when things get bad. What I'm talking about of course as a true friend, but that kind of person is hard to find today, isn't it? Jesse had never met or talked to Pamela, but he was curious. He wrote back, telling her
在家族餐馆工作。杰西最喜欢的信件来自一个叫帕梅拉的女人。我，是的，我通常在一天的末尾收到信时读它们，回到我的房间，躺在床上，坐在那里读。亲爱的杰西，内心深处你和我一样清楚，如果你身边能有一个人，你的生活会比现在好得多。一个会帮助你、鼓励你、和你一起努力、即使事情变糟也对你不离不弃的人。我所说的当然是一个真正的朋友，但这种人在今天很难找到，不是吗？杰西从未见过或交谈过帕梅拉，但他很好奇。他回了信，向她讲述了。
a little about himself, and Pamela replied again and again. The letters were typed in a girlish font and signed in a blue pen with big, loopy letters. In another letter, Pamela wrote, just before I sat down to write this letter to you, I was thinking how lucky I am that in this great, big, crazy world, I found you. I hope I can be part of your life for a long time, darling, and I hope as time goes by, I'll be able to make you happier and happier. This mystery woman seemed to know him. She made Jesse feel understood. She made him feel loved.
关于他自己的一点事，帕梅拉一次又一次地回信。信是用少女风的字体打印的，并用蓝色钢笔签上了大写、连笔的字。在另一封信中，帕梅拉写道，就在我坐下来给你写这封信之前，我在想我是多么幸运，在这个又大又疯狂的世界里，我找到了你。我希望我能长期成为你生活的一部分，亲爱的，我希望随着时间的推移，我能让你越来越快乐。这个神秘的女人似乎很了解他。她让杰西感到被理解。她让他感受到了被爱。
You can tell when you meet a person that they're not superficial, this is coming from their heart. Everybody's looking for that perfect love and everything. And this pops up so I thought, well, could this be something different? This was Pamela. He was mid-laid, balding, and had a small grey mustache. His real name was Don Lowry. Was any of it difficult to come up with these characters as the characters bore you? Tell me about it as a writing project.
当你遇到一个人时，你能看出他们并不浮于表面，这是发自内心的。每个人都在寻找那种完美的爱情。而这突然出现了，所以我想，这会不会有什么不同？这就是帕梅拉。他中年，谢顶，留着一小撮灰色胡子。他的真名是唐·洛里。创造这些角色有什么困难吗，这些角色会让你厌烦吗？跟我讲讲把它当成一个写作项目吧。
No, I was looking to photograph a girl and say, what kind of girl is this? Where is she from? What she likes to do? It was fairly easy after a while. The first 20 were a little bit rough, but the next 80 were not hard at all. And you enjoyed making up these carrots. I loved it. I loved it. I meant that. Don died in 2014, but I met him in 2011 in a rundown house in Butler, Pennsylvania. He was 82. If you have trouble understanding Don's voice, it's because he was a lifelong, heavy smoker. The desk in his living room was covered with ash, his sofa smelled of smoke. Don told me he always wanted to be a writer, but his real talent wasn't being a hustler. He always had a scheme going.
没有，我当时想拍一个女孩的照片，然后问：这是个什么样的女孩？她来自哪里？她喜欢做什么过家家？过了一会儿这相当容易。前20个有点艰难，但接下来的80个一点也不难。你很享受捏造这些角色吗？我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我是认真的。唐于2014年逝世，但我是在2011年宾夕法尼亚州巴特勒的一栋破旧房子里见到他的。他当时82岁。如果你听不懂唐的声音，那是因为他是个有一辈子烟瘾的老烟民。他客厅的桌子上满是烟灰，沙发上弥漫着烟味。唐告诉我，他一直想成为一名作家，但他真正的天赋不是写作，而是当骗子。他总是有各种诡计。
In his early 30s, Don visited Mexico and wrote a traveler's guide where he explained how American men could live cheaply there, pick up women, and get by with rudimentary Spanish. It was called Mexico Bathurst Paradise. It didn't sell. And then he tried something, most writers would never consider. He changed the name of the book's author to a woman's name. Sales開rocketed, he said. Apparently, lonely American men didn't want tips from a guy, they wanted tips from a girl.
30岁出头时，唐游历了墨西哥，并写了一本旅行指南，在书中他解释了美国男人如何在当地廉价生活、泡妞，并用蹩脚的西班牙语应付。这本书叫《墨西哥巴瑟斯特天堂》。它没卖出去。然后他尝试了一件大多数作家绝不会考虑的事情：他把书的作者名字改成了女性的名字。他说，销量飙升。显然，孤独的美国男人不想听一个男人的建议，他们想要女人的建议。
Don realized there was a market waiting to be exploited. He rented mailing lists from magazines that catered to single men and started writing letters to them, posing as different women. Men like Jesse were invited to join a club where, in exchange for a small fee, they could receive love letters. In a moment of inspiration, Don decided to call the women who wrote the letters Angels, Angel Linda, Angel Christina, Angel Palmer. He purchased stock photos of models and printed catalogs with photos and bios for each angel.
唐意识到有一个等待被开拓的市场。他从迎合单身男子的杂志那里租用邮件名单，并伪装成不同的女人开始给他们写信。像杰西这样的男人被邀请加入一个俱乐部，在那里，只需支付一小笔费用，他们就能收到情书。在一时灵感迸发之下，唐决定把写信的女人称为“天使”——天使琳达、天使克里斯蒂娜、天使帕尔默。他购买了模特的库存照片，并印刷了带有每位天使照片和个人简介的目录。
Angels came in different flavors, some were compliant, helpless and pure, others were raunchy and sent nude photos of themselves. Most were young and all were eager to please. Dream women, for a certain kind of man, dreamed up of course, by another man. In one brochure Angel Linda Scott is pictured in a one-piece swimsuit on her hands and knees. Angel Christina looks like an idealistic woman. She's shown hugging a tree and holding a flower. I prefer a certain type of man, Christina says.
天使们有着不同的风格：有些顺从、无助且纯洁；另一些则很风骚，会寄来自己的裸照。大多数都很年轻，而且都急于取悦他人。对于特定类型的男人来说，这是梦中情人；当然，这是由另一个男人梦想出来的。在一份宣传册中，天使琳达·斯科特身穿连体泳衣，双手双膝着地。天使克里斯蒂娜看起来像一个理想主义女性。画面中她拥抱着一棵树，手里拿着一朵花。“我更喜欢特定类型的男人，”克里斯蒂娜说。
He can pick up a handful of dark, rich soil and feel a kind of reverence and joy. But he's awfully hard to find. Don mailed his brochures to men like Jesse. If a man wrote back, Don began sending letters to him as Angel Christina or Angel Linda. Don told me he didn't want members who were just looking for sex.
他可以抓起一把深色、肥沃的泥土，感受到一种敬畏和喜悦。但他实在太难找了。唐把他的宣传册寄给了像杰西这样的男人。如果有人回信，唐就开始以天使克里斯蒂娜或天使琳达的身份给他回信。唐告诉我，他并不想要那些仅仅寻找性关系的会员。
He wanted men looking for meaningful relationships who would be in it for the long haul. He thought this would be better for business and better for the marks. Yeah, the guy, his wife died, you know, and he was living alone. He didn't have any friends. You know, that kind of thing. He needed this. He didn't have anything or anybody else to turn him up. No, nobody. We didn't.
他想要的是寻找有意义的关系、并愿意长久相伴的男人。他认为这对外生意和那些受骗者都更好。是的，那家伙，他妻子去世了，你知道的，他独自生活。他没有任何朋友。你知道，诸如此类的事情。他需要这个。他没有其他任何人或事可以求助。不，没有人。我们没有。
These girls would boost their egos. You know, things like, all your handwriting is so masculine. Things like that. Little things. Give the guy a boost. And they loved it. After a few letters to Jesse, Pamela let him know that the only thing she wanted was a little help. Darling, I want you to know that I really love writing you every day.
这些女孩会提升他们的自尊心。你知道的，比如，“你的字迹真有男人味”之类的话。诸如此类的事。一些小事情。给这家伙打打气。他们很喜欢这样。在给杰西写了信之后，帕梅拉让他知道，她唯一想要的就是一点帮助。亲爱的，我想让你知道，我真的很喜欢每天给你写信。
It has filled a great need in my life and I know I'd be very sad if I had to stop writing you and being your friend. I hope you feel the same way about me and my letters to you. I think it's fair and reasonable for me to ask you to help with the expenses of paper, envelopes, postage, photos, and the other things I'll be sending you. If you could send me just $10 a week for my letters, I could continue writing every day as I have been. Jesse was fine with that. He figures he sent in four of $5,000 between 1985 and 88.
它填补了我生活中的巨大需求，我知道如果我不得不停止写信和做你的朋友，我会非常难过。我希望你对我以及我给你的信也有同样的感受。我认为我请你帮忙分担纸张、信封、邮资、照片以及我将寄给你的其他物品的费用，是公平且合情合理的。如果你能每周只寄给我10美元作为信件费用，我就可以像以前一样继续每天写作。杰西对此表示接受。他估计自己在1985年到1988年间总共寄出了四五千美元。
It wasn't a big deal to him. My business was prospering pretty well. We ran over $100,000, three years in a row, so there was no problem for me to be sending money and stuff stuff so. Pamela often sent Jesse stories about the two of them for a little extra money. In one, Pamela and Jesse go on a picnic together. In another, he literally rescues her as a knight in shining armor.
对他来说这不算什么大事。我的生意进展得很顺利。我们连续三年营业额超过十万美元，所以我寄钱之类的事情完全没有问题。帕梅拉经常给杰西寄一些关于他们俩的故事，以换取一点额外的钱。其中一个故事里，帕梅拉和杰西一起去野餐。另一个故事里，他真的像身穿闪亮盔甲的骑士一样拯救了她。
This one story that has them both lying on a bear skin rug in front of a fireplace. And of course, it goes where you think it will go if two people are lying on a bear skin rug in front of a fireplace. And of course, it goes where you think it will go if two people are lying on a bear skin rug in front of a fireplace. But it's romantic, not explicit. The language is tame. The letter concludes, I lay beside you and whispered goodnight my sweet darling. Let us drift away to paradise in our dreams and wake up together to a new and wonderful day. I kiss you gently and fall asleep in your arms. Okay, obviously cheesy. Don Lowry was not a gifted writer, but he was a gifted manipulator. When I first heard about the story, I assumed the men who signed up for the letters from the angels must have been such easy marks, so naive, who else would buy such absurd
这个故事里，他们俩躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上。当然，如果两个人躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上，事情就会向你想象的方向发展。当然，如果两个人躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上，事情就会向你想象的方向发展。但那是浪漫的，而不是露骨的。语言很温和。信的结尾写道：“我躺在你身边，轻声说晚安，我亲爱的甜心。让我们在梦中飘向天堂，一起醒来迎接美好崭新的一天。我温柔地吻你，在你怀里睡着。”好吧，这显然很老土。唐·洛里并不是一个有天赋的作家，但他是一个有天赋的操纵者。当我第一次听说这个故事时，我以为那些注册接收天使信件的男人们一定很容易受骗，太天真了，否则谁会买这种荒谬的。
fantasies? But then I read the dozens and dozens of letters that Pamela sent Jesse. He saved them in a large binder, each letter in its own plastic sleeve. And as I read the letters, I started to understand the power of the psychological tools Don used to hook men like Jesse. Most of the letters aren't epic fantasies. Most are about the minutiae of Pamela's life. She goes to the bank, she talks to co-workers, she tells Jesse her thoughts on televangelis. Over and over Pamela tells Jesse how much he
幻想呢？但随后我读了帕梅拉写给杰西的几十封信。他把它们存放在一个大文件夹里，每封信都有自己的塑料封套。当我阅读这些信件时，我开始理解唐用来吸引像杰西这样的男人的心理工具的力量。大多数信件都不是史诗般的幻想。大多数都是关于帕梅拉生活的琐事。她去银行，她和同事聊天，她告诉杰西她对电视布道者的看法。帕梅拉一次又一次地告诉杰西他有多重要。
means to her. She praises him, encourages him. When you read the letters one after the other, like Jessie did day after day after day, it paints a picture that feels real. I felt the Pamela and the letters was a real person, and I knew Don was writing them. There were other tricks. In one letter Pamela asked Jessie to keep a picture of hers nearby as he read her letters so he would feel she was in the room with him. Jessie put up two photos of her on the wall.
对她而言。她赞美他，鼓励他。当你像杰西那样日复一日地连续阅读这些信件时，它描绘出了一幅感觉真实的画面。我觉得信中的帕梅拉是一个真实的人，而我知道是唐在写这些信。还有别的诡计。在一封信中，帕梅拉让杰西在读信时把她的照片放在附近，这样他就会觉得她和他在同一个房间里。杰西把她的两张照片贴在了墙上。
She once sent him a dime. In that letter, she told Jessie she had just had a strange day. Another driver bashed her car, but didn't leave a note. Just when it looked like the day couldn't get any worse, she lost her purse. Depressed, Pamela spotted this very dime on the street. She picked it up, hoping it was a lucky charm. Later, a little boy showed up with her purse. A woman called and took responsibility for the street. She picked it up, hoping it was a lucky charm. Later, a little boy showed
她曾寄给他一毛钱。在那封信里，她告诉杰西她刚刚度过了奇怪的一天。另一个司机撞了她的车，却没有留便条。正当看起来糟糕透顶时，她又丢了钱包。沮丧的帕梅拉在街上发现了这一毛钱。她把它捡起来，希望它能带来好运。后来，一个小男孩带着她的钱包出现了。一个女人打电话承认了街上的事。她把它捡起来，希望它能带来好运。后来，一个小男孩带着。
up with her purse. A woman called and took responsibility for the car. Pamela told Jesse she was giving him her lucky dime. Here's Jesse reading from the end of that letter. Keep this dime darling. Letters always remind you that good people can still come into your life, and good things can still happen to you, and also think of this as a small token of my affection for you. If you hold it in your hand and squeeze it hard, you feel the warmth of my love coming out of it. Did you actually do that, Jesse? Yes, I think I did do that in everything. Like I said, Jesse's mother had recently died and his dad had heart trouble.
她的钱包出现了。一个女人打电话承认了车祸的事。帕梅拉告诉杰西，她要把她幸运的一毛钱送给他。这里是杰西朗读那封信的结尾。留着这封信，亲爱的。信总是提醒你，好人仍然会走进你的生活，美好的事情仍然会发生在你身上，也把这当作我对你爱意的一个小小的信物。如果你把它握在手里，用力捏它，你会感觉到我的爱从里面散发出来的温暖。你真的那样做了吗，杰西？是的，我想我在每件事上都那样做了。就像我说的，杰西的母亲最近去世了，他父亲有心脏病。
He spent a lot of time looking after him. He wrote letters to Pamela, confiding in her about his depression. She sent him heartfelt letters about bad relationships she'd had, and she told him about visiting her grandfather who was suffering from dementia. That really took its toll on her, so I kind of bonded with that, knowing that she was going through the same thing that I was me and her kind of more or less bonded
他花了大量时间照顾他。他给帕梅拉写信，向她倾诉他的抑郁。她给他写了感人的信，讲述了她经历过的糟糕感情，她还告诉他关于探望患有痴呆症的祖父的事。这确实让她心力交瘁，所以我对这一点产生了共鸣，知道她和我经历了同样的事情，我和她多多少少比我交谈过的任何人。
more than any other person I've ever talked to. It was kind of like beacon from outside. It was like if you were a ship out at sea and you were looking for a lighthouse which they used that in the deal to look for the light and everything and guide yourself towards it where you know that you'll have safe haven. I'm not sure I'm exactly following you. Is this something from one of the letters where they basically talk about the lighthouse? Yes, and in fact I got a little wooden figure of a lighthouse that she sent to me at one time and everything. I said, let this be can know that somebody's out there looking out for you and everything. everything. If Jesse had wanted to see it, there were plenty of signs the letters were mass-produced.
更具共鸣。它就像来自外部的灯塔。就像如果你是一艘在大海航行的船，你在寻找灯塔——他们在这场骗局里用了这个词来寻找光芒等等，指引自己走向它，在那里你知道你会有安全的避风港。我不确定我完全明白你的意思。这是信中谈到灯塔的内容吗？是的，事实上我得到了她曾经寄给我的一个木制小灯塔模型等等。我说，让这个发光，知道外面有人在看着你。如果杰西想要看出来的话，有很多迹象表明这些信件是批量生产的。
They looked typed, but the paper doesn't have the indentations that come from tie-priter keys. The signatures look like they've been stamped or printed. All the specifics in the letters are about Pamela's life. In the letters did Pamela ever ask you how you were handling your mom's death? I'm not that I remember no animal thinks though. Did she ask how your dad's health was? Not that I remember it this time no. In fact when I read Pamela's letters to Jessie, she never mentions any of the things
它们看起来像是打印的，但纸张没有打字机按键留下的压痕。签名看起来像是盖上去的或者印刷的。信中的所有细节都是关于帕梅拉的生活的。在信中，帕梅拉有没有问过你是怎么处理你妈妈的去世的？我不记得了，不过没有什么想法。她问过你爸爸的健康状况吗？我不记得这次有了，没有。事实上，当我读帕梅拉写给杰西的信时，她从没有提到任何他说过的话。
he's told her. When Pamela talks about Jessie's life, she switches into generalities. I know you're sad, I know you're lonely, I know you're having a hard time. The only way the letters are personalized is that Jessie's name is sprinkled throughout, auto-filled, like a madlib sheet.
事情。当帕梅拉谈到杰西的生活时，她改用了泛泛而谈。我知道你很伤心，我知道你很孤独，我知道你正经历艰难时期。这些信件唯一实现个性化的地方，就是杰西的名字被点缀在各处，像玩“疯狂填词”游戏一样自动填入。
To Jessie, it didn't matter. He saw what he wanted to see. At the time, I wasn't really fully absorbing all of that. I had a lot of my plate kind of in turmoil with everything that was going on. So I just read them and it kind of took some encouragement out of it. Did you ever have doubts about what was going on as you were receiving the letters? Well, no, not at the time and everything. Like I said, I was glad to be getting letters from somebody, and even though you're paying
对杰西来说，这并不重要。他看到了他想看的东西。当时，我并没有真正完全消化所有这些。我有很多事情要处理，随着发生的一切，一切都陷入混乱。所以我只是读了它们，并从中得到了一些鼓励。在你收到信的时候，你有没有怀疑过发生了什么？嗯，没有，当时没有。就像我说的，我很高兴能收到某人的信，尽管你要为此付钱，因为你戴着眼罩，并没有真正注意到所有这些。就像我说的，当你不是世界上最好看的人时，有人突然，写信给你，对你诉说并振奋你的精神等等。因为每个人都看着你。这有点像《巴黎圣母院》里的驼背。你永远找不到会在乎你的人，但他们最后。
money for that, because you have blinders on and not really paying attention to all of that. Like I said, when you're not the best looking person in the world, that somebody out of the blue, the right to you and tell you things and kind of build up your spirits and everything and stuff. Because everybody looks at you and stuff. It's kind of like the deal with a hunchback of Notre Dame. You'll never find anybody that'll care for you, but they are at the end.
他最终与那些对友好待他的人成了朋友。在某个时刻，帕梅拉成了让杰西在不得不长时间工作、不得不关闭餐厅并急忙送父亲去医院时勉强支撑下去的精神支柱。我，是的，有一件事真的让我很触动，我当时正打算。
He wound up making a friend with the people that befriended him and everything. At a certain point, Pamela became the thing that kept Jesse afloat when he had to work long hours, when he had to close his restaurant and rush his father to the hospital. I, yes, there was one thing that really kind of touched me in everything I was telling
我准备放弃了，她只是告诉我，振作起来，所以这真的成了鼓励的话。随着时间的推移，唐意识到他的会员们已经上钩了，他可以把这个幻想推得更远，远得多。他为他的天使们创造了一个史诗般的世界，有着神奇的背景故事和奇妙的未来。它是这样运作的。天使们据说一起住在远离尘世的隐蔽避难所里，大多数都是。
I'm ready to give up and everything and she just told me, get back on your feet and everything so that really was a word of encouragement and everything. As Don went on, he realized his members were hooked and he could take the fantasy further, much further. He invented an epic world for his angels with a magical backstory and a fantastic future. Here's how it worked. The angels supposedly lived together in a retreat hidden away from the world, most were
逃离毒品和坏男人的迷失灵魂。这些是需要稳重的手和坚实肩膀的女人。随着他发明更多天使，唐想出了交织在一起的背景故事。有些天使是好的，有些是坏的，天使们互相帮助，背后捅刀子。所有报名加入“孤独男士俱乐部”的男士都明白，他们加入的是一个由心地善良、致力于照顾天使的男士组成的组织。这个组织被称为卡乌尔。唐向卡乌尔的成员承诺，有一天他们会和天使一起搬到一个山谷天堂，搬进一栋形状像裸体女性的巨型建筑里。
lost souls escaping drugs and bad men. These were women who needed a steady hand and a strong shoulder. As he invented more angels, Don came up with interweaving backstories. Some angels were good, some bad, angels helped one another, backstabbed each other. All the men who signed up to join the Lonely Hats Club understood they were joining an organization of good-hearted men who were devoted to taking care of the angels. The organization was known as the Kha'ul. Don promised members of the Kha'ul that they would one day move with the angels to a valley paradise into a giant building shaped like a naked woman
躺在草地上。这栋女人形状的建筑将容纳会议室和礼堂。这个天堂将被命名为肖恩达扎。作为捐款的回报，会员们的需求将在肖恩达扎得到照顾，所有的需求。在这场反幻想的中心是一位女族长，一位名叫玛丽亚母亲的圣洁女性。玛丽亚收集并管理会员们的资金，她组织并管束天使们。据说她拥有神秘的力量，能够让堕落的女性重归纯洁。有玛丽亚母亲的照片。她很漂亮。玛丽亚的照片其实是。
lying down on the grass. This lady-shaped building would house meeting rooms and auditoriums. The paradise was to be called Shondaza. In exchange for that contributions, the members would have their needs looked after at Shondaza, all their needs. At the center of the Antifantasy was a matriarch, a saintly woman named Mother Maria. Maria collected and managed the money from the members and she organized and disciplined the angels. She was said to have mystical powers and could re-virginize fallen women. There were photos of Mother Maria. She was beautiful. Maria's photos were actually
一个叫埃丝特的女人。她是唐的妻子。并非卡乌尔的所有成员都相信昌达扎。杰西把描述昌达扎的信塞进了文件夹的后袋里。他觉得这只是帕梅拉的一些古怪想法，就没管它。但还有其他觉得这个骗局很诱人的鱼。在我的心里，我一直保留着这样一个领域，尽量不被说服，你知道，百分之百地相信，你知道，毫无疑问，你知道，这好得让人难以置信。这是肯·布兰查德。他是一个温和的大块头，也是卡乌尔多年的另一位成员。
for a woman named Esther. She was Don's wife. Not all the members of the call believed in Chandaza. Jesse stuffed the letters describing Chandaza in the back pocket of the call believed in Shandaza. Jesse stuffed the letters describing Shandaza in the back pocket of the binder. He figured it was just some wacky idea Pamela had and just ignored it. But there were other fish who found this hoax tempting. In my mind, I always held this area of, tried not to be convinced, you know, 100% about it, you know, assurably, you know, it's too good to be true. This is Ken Blanchard. He's a big gentle man and was another member of the call for many years.
他加入时是单身，2012年我遇到他时他依然单身。吸引力在哪里？当你对自己说“你知道，这好得难以置信”时，你是怎么想的？嗯，我想对我和我来说，前景也许至少能和一些女性进行某种交流，也许和我年龄相仿，也许比我小一点，甚至可能那样。但这听起来像是个好主意，你知道，站在某种前沿之类的。哦天哪，我不知道。什么？
He was single when he joined, and he was still single when I met him in 2012. What was the draw? What did you tell yourself when you said, you know, this is too good to be true? Well, I think with me it was the prospect of maybe at least having some sort of communication with some women, maybe my age, maybe a little bit too young for me, maybe even then. But it sounded like a kind of a neat idea, you know, to be kind of on the leading edge or something like that, you know. Oh geez, I don't know. What?
我不知道该怎么解释我这一部分的想法，或者我对它的信仰之类的事情。他们让我上钩了，你知道的，他们说的话等等，我相信了他们。唐每年都有数百个新注册用户。数百万美元流入了唐位于伊利诺伊州莫林的总部。他给自己买了好车，一辆劳斯莱斯和一辆梅赛德斯。他给他的儿子们和埃丝特买下了他们想要的一切。他在莫林市中心买下了一间大办公室，并经营一家印刷厂。他雇用了助理、销售人员和代笔人来扩展他的业务。
I don't know what else to try to explain my part of it or belief in it or anything. They got me hooked, you know, on what they were saying and everything, and I believed them. Don got hundreds of new signups every year. Millions of dollars flowed back to Don's headquarters in Malin, Illinois. He bought himself expensive cars, a Rolls Royce, and a Mercedes. He bought his sons and ester everything they wanted. He got a big office in downtown Malin and operated a print shop. He hired assistants, salespeople, and ghost writers to expand his operation.
到了20世纪80年代中期，唐正在给3万多名男性写情书。我们有律师、医生、教授、机械师、制造商，应有尽有。各种各样的人都是会员。我们甚至还有一个牧师加入卡乌尔。真的吗？等等，那不是天主教神父吧。对，天主教神父。他希望能从中得到什么？鬼知道呢。
By the mid-1980s, Don was writing love letters to more than 30,000 men. We had lawyers, doctors, professors, mechanics, makers, you name it. All kinds of people were members. We even had a priest join the call. Really? Wait, that's not a Catholic priest. Yeah, Catholic priest. What was he hoping to get out of it? Who the hell knows?
可能就是好奇吧。为了开拓这个不断扩大的市场，唐不断试验新的计划和产品。他开始出售天使向男人们调情的磁带。他涉足周边商品。马克杯、拼图、纪念币，上面都印着天使的脸。我们寄出了一个印有天使特里脸庞的枕套。每天晚上和天使特里睡觉一定很生气。哦，我们知道很多这样的事情。会员们不仅仅寄现金和支票。
There was probably this board. To exploit this growing market, Don constantly experimented with news, schemes and products. He started selling cassette tapes where the angels flurded with the men. He got into merch. Monks, puzzles, commemorative coins, all with angels faces printed on them. And we sent out a pillowcase with Angel Terri's face on it. It's an angry sleep with Angel Terri every night. Oh, we know a lot of things like that. The members won just sending in cash and checks.
他们还寄礼物。肯给天使瓦妮莎寄了一件风衣。其他人寄了外套和鞋子。甚至还有园艺设备，以便天使们能在他们秘密的避难所里种植蔬菜。你鼓励他们寄私人物品吗？哦，不！不。我很讨厌那样。
They were sending gifts. Ken sent Angel Vanessa a windbreaker. Others sent coats and shoes. Even gardening equipment so the angels could grow vegetables at their secret retreat. Did you encourage them to send personal items? Oh no! No. I hated that.
这里有个家伙，他妻子死了。她留下了各种各样的首饰、裙子等等。把它们装进一个大纸箱里寄给我们。我们拿这能怎么办呢？那么，你想要的当然是让他们寄张支票。对，当然。或者钱、现金之类的。
Here's the guy, his wife died. And she left all kind of jewelry and dresses and so on. Put them in a big cardboard box and mail it to us. What the hell are we gonna do with it? Now, what you wanted, of course, was you wanted them to send a check. Yeah, of course. Or money or a cash or anything.
你告诉过他们不要这样做吗？很少这样。我不想伤害他们的感情。他们以为通过寄这些衣服是在为卡乌尔做一件伟大的事。我是说，我不想伤害他们。我爸会把内衣摆出来。他会举行人行道促销活动。内衣、礼物和珠宝。这是唐的儿子里科·洛里。
Did you tell them not to do it? Very suddenly. I don't want to hurt their feelings. They thought they were doing a great thing for the usual by saying that these clothes. I mean, I don't want to hurt them. My dad would blaze in legias. He would have sidewalks sales. lingerie and gifts and jewelry. This is Don Sun, Rico Larry.
我爸会把内衣摆在……你会在印刷厂前挂着的架子上卖内衣吗？他居然会在印刷厂门前的人行道上支起货架？是的。是的。我爸有一种非常讽刺且恶劣的幽默感。当地一名警官告诉我，来自全国各地的男士开始出现在莫林，询问他们去哪里能找到天使。
And my dad would blaze in the league just... You'd be selling the lingerie on racks in front of the print shop. He would actually put up racks on the sidewalk in front of the print shop? Yep. Yep. My dad had a very sarcastic and wicked sense of humor. A local police officer told me men from all over the country started showing up in Malin asking where they could find the angels.
如果他们找到了印刷厂，唐就会报警。唐发现警察试图向男人们解释，根本没有天使瓦妮莎，没有避难所，也没有肖恩达扎。但偶尔，如果唐心情好，他真的会允许他们与女性员工见面，他曾让这些员工在照片中冒充天使。随着时间的推移，唐甚至为他最忠诚的会员举办了与天使见面的活动。他称之为聚会。在芝加哥的聚会上，一位建议专栏作家提出了约会建议，一位喜剧演员讲了笑话。
If they found their way to the print shop, Don called the cops on them. Don found it police tried to explain to the men that there was no angel Vanessa, no retreat, no shondaza. But occasionally, if Don was in the mood, he'd actually allow them to meet female employees whom he had asked to pose as angels in photos. In time, Don even set up events for his most loyal members to meet the angels. He called them gatherings. At the gathering in Chicago, an advice columnist offered dating suggestions, a comedian told
穿着黄绿色衣服的天使们在舞台上跳着现代舞蹦蹦跳跳。杰西去了莫林的聚会。他很高兴终于见到帕梅拉了。她看起来和照片里一模一样。事实上，她是唐的一名员工，她的名字确实叫帕梅拉。她热情地向杰西打招呼。但杰西的兴奋之情被聚会上还有十几个其他男人的事实冲淡了。
jokes. Angels and yellow-green dresses leapt around on stage in an interpretive dance. Jessie went to the Moline gathering. He was excited to finally meet Pamela. She looked just like she did in her pictures. In fact, she was one of Don's employees, and her name really was Pamela. She greeted Jessie warmly. But Jessie's excitement was tempered by the fact that there were a dozen other men at the gathering.
杰西惊讶地发现，每个男人都以为自己也和帕梅拉谈着恋爱。他们簇拥在她周围，争夺她的注意力。然后就在那时我突然醒悟了，说，嘿，这根本不是我想象的那样。这是一场骗局。嗯，这感觉就像肚子挨了一拳。这令人沮丧等等。我们把所有的钱都投进去了，结果快到头了。事情并不是它原本该有的样子。它让你认清了现实等等，所以。
Jesse was shocked to find that every man thought he was in a personal relationship with Pamela too. They crowded around her, vying for her attention. And then that's when it dawned on me and said, hey, this is not what I thought it would be or anything. That it was a ripoff. Well, that was kind of like getting a kick in the stomach. It was upsetting and everything. We sent all that money in this net near the end. It wasn't what it was meant to be. It got you down to reality and stuff, so.
杰西知道帕梅拉喜欢八音盒，所以他买了一个昂贵的八音盒，上面有一个小唱片，当《圣徒行进》播放时，唱片就会转动。帕梅拉非常喜欢它。他说她盯着它看，任由唱片播放。它一遍又一遍地播放着。其他男人站在他们周围，看着杰西。他们看着帕梅拉，然后又看着杰西。他很喜欢自己让他们感到嫉妒。杰西并不怪帕梅拉。他不太确定这个骗局是如何运作的，但他确信。
Jesse knew that Pamela lacked music boxes, so he bought an expensive one with a tiny record on it that played when the Saints go marching in. Pamela loved it. He says she stared at it and let the record play. It went on and on and on. The other men stood around them and looked at Jessie. They looked at Pamela, then back to Jessie. He liked that he was making them jealous. Jessie didn't blame Pamela. He wasn't exactly sure how the scam worked, but he was sure
眼前这个女人就是给他写信的那个女人，就是读过他信件的人。证据呢？帕梅拉的狗跳到了他的腿上。她跳到了他的膝盖上。我们联系了帕梅拉，看她是否还记得这些，但她拒绝接受录音采访。她确实证实了她没有写过这些信。杰西在聚会上和其他几个男人交朋友，特别是两个叫兰尼和艾尔的家伙。他们就像是互不相识却各自多年观看同一部肥皂剧的陌生人。嗯，我们聊了起来。
that the woman standing before him was the same woman who wrote to him, that she was the one who had read his letters. The proof? Pamela's dog jumped into his lap. She jumped on his lap. We got in touch with Pamela to see if she remembered any of this, but she declined to be interviewed on tape for the story. She did confirm that she hadn't written the letters. Jesse made friends with a couple of other men at the meeting, particularly two guys named Lenny and Al. They were all like strangers who had independently watched the same soap opera for many years. Well we got to talking
谈论这件事并说，好吧，你为什么要写信给这个等等？我们没有和女孩们建立联系，反而最终互相交谈，结识了新朋友，并谈论了我们遇到的麻烦。所以我们有点，嗯，他们就像我一样等等。所以我们保持着书信往来，就像他们说的那样。他们给我写信，甚至还打到我的餐厅来问我情况怎么样等等，打听并询问我爸爸的情况等等，所以听到有人打电话来关心你，感觉很鼓舞人心。换句话说，他们打听了所有帕梅拉从未打听过的私事。
about it and say well why did you write on to this and everything? Instead of bonding with the girls we ended up talking each other and meeting new friends and talking about the troubles we had. So we kind of, well they were just like me and everything. So we stayed in correspondence like they said. They wrote me letters and they even called me at my restaurant to ask me how things were going and everything and finding out, asking about my dad and everything so that kind of was encouraging to hear somebody calling to want to check on you and everything. In other words, they asked about all the personal stuff Pamela never asked about.
兰尼和艾尔与他保持联系直到他们去世。最终终结唐·洛里骗局的是一个名叫苏珊·拉索斯的女人。她是唐曾合作过的一位模特。她遭遇了一场车祸，打电话向唐求助。他带着摄影师出现在医院。他们解开她的绷带，拍了照片。他们把这些寄给所有与天使苏珊通信的男人们，并请求他们资助支付她的医疗费用。
Lenny and Al stayed in touch until they died. What finally brought Don Lowry's cam to an end was a woman named Susan Rassos. She was a model that Don had worked with. She had gotten into a car crash and called Don for help. He showed up at the hospital with a photographer. The unbandaged her wounds and took pictures. They sent these to all the men who were corresponding with the angel Susan and asked them for help in paying her medical bills.
但唐并没有把钱给苏珊。她报警了。她来到了我们的办公室。她揭露了洛里先生对她作出却又打破的承诺。洛里先生获得的收益在金钱上是惊人的。这是莫林警察局中尉肯尼斯·雷克斯罗斯。他多年来一直知道唐·洛里的存在。他拒绝了许多来到警察局寻找天使的男士，他一直在寻找。
But Don didn't give Susan the money. She went to the cops. And she came to our office. She revealed the promise that Mr. Lowry had made to her and broken. The return that Mr. Lowry received was staggering in terms of dollars and cents. This is Lieutenant Kenneth Rex Roth of the Moline Police Department. He'd been aware of Don Lowry for years. He turned away many men who'd come to the police station in search of the angels, and he'd
一直寻找关押唐的方法。他非常腹黑。他是个阴险的人。我认为洛里先生是一个邪恶的人。”但多亏了苏珊·拉索斯，警方终于有了获得传唤令的证据。他们突击搜查了唐的印刷厂。他们发现有些男人卖掉了一切，只为了把毕生积蓄交给天使。有个男人住在车里，把他的社保支票寄给他的天使。
been looking for a way to lock Don up. He was very diabolical. He's a sinister person. I consider Mr. Lowry to be an evil man." But thanks to Susan Rassow, the police finally had evidence to obtain subpoenas. They raided Don's print shop. They found out that some men sold everything in order to give their life savings to the angels. One man lived out of his car and forwarded his social security check to his angel.
当警察联系到这些男人时，他们中的许多人第一次意识到他们珍视的信件是一个男人写的。我感到愤怒和尴尬的，比什么都多的是，我甚至卷入其中的事实。任何男人竟然卷入了这其中。再次说明，这是肯·布兰查德，他多年来一直收到天使瓦妮莎的信。当我发现我这些天一直收到的这些信件，而我以为是某个女孩在和我分享一些东西，你知道。
When the police got in touch with these guys, many of them realized for the first time that their treasured letters were written by a man. What I was turned out to be angry about and more embarrassed about, more than anything, was the fact that he was even involved. Any man at all was even involved. Again, this is Ken Blanchard, who spent years receiving letters from Angel Vanessa. When I found out that these letters I'd been getting all these times, and I thought it was some girl sharing something, you know, with me.
然后我发现那是他，就在这鬼东西里，你知道，我想，天哪，我到底卷入了什么鬼地方？但是，我现在可以对此一笑了之，但我认为当时我确实对此有一些感受。它们可不算仁慈。嗯哼。唐的律师说，如果会员们相信天使是真实的，那是他们自己的事。
Well, then I found out it was him, and right in the darn thing, you know, I thought, my God, what the hell am I getting into? But, I could laugh about now, but I think at the time I did have some feelings about that. They weren't very charitable. Mm-hmm. Don's lawyer said that if members believed the angels were real, that was on them.
正如唐多年后对我说的那样，人们只相信他们愿意相信的。你无法说服他们。大多数会员相信天使永远活在一个叫做避难所的永无乡里。我们告诉他们她们永生不老。这能说明什么吗？好吧，你惊讶于他们相信了你？是的。它帮了你，伙计。我是说，我很开心，所以这算什么大不了的。唐和帕梅拉被控邮件欺诈、阴谋罪和洗钱罪。
As Don told me many years later, people believe what they want to believe. You cannot dissuade them. Most members believe angels live forever and a never-never-land called retreat. We told them they live forever and never grew old. Does that tell you anything? Well, you're surprised that they believed you? Yeah. It has helped you, man. I mean, I'm happy, so big deal. Don and Pamela were charged with male fraud, conspiracy, and money laundering.
媒体蜂拥至审判现场。唐在媒体中身败名裂，《人物》杂志称他为卖大力丸的江湖骗子。这让我想起了当初是什么让我对这个故事感兴趣，真正让我惊讶的事情。许多会员从全国各地飞来，出现在法院外为卡乌尔辩护，有些人举着标语在外面捍卫兄弟会。杰西和他的朋友艾尔都在那里，当他们在法庭外等待时，杰西看到帕梅拉走了过来。
The press mobbed the trial. Don was shamed in the press, called a snake oil salesman in People magazine. Which brings me back to what got me interested in the story in the first place, the thing that really surprised me. Many members flew from all over the country to show up at the courthouse in defense of the call, sums to the outside with picket science defending the brotherhood. Jesse and his friend Al were both there, as they waited outside the courtroom, Jesse saw Pamela come up.
他冲了过去。她正走过来，我注意到她很冷，所以我脱下夹克披在她的肩膀上，我们一直走到法院，那有点像保安，等她走进室内后，我脱下外套，退了回去。她当时对你说了什么吗？没有，没说什么。会员们在证人席上作证，称卡乌尔是他们生命中至关重要、美好的一部分。
He rushed over to her. She was walking up, and I noticed she was cold, so I took off my jacket and draped it over her shoulders, and we walked all the way up to the courthouse that was kind of like a security guard, and after she went indoors, I took my coat off, and I backed off and everything. Did she say anything to you at that point? No, not really. Members testified on the stand and said the call had been a critical, beautiful part of their lives.
一个人说天使的信救了他，让他免于酗酒和自杀的念头。杰西也作证了。这是他宣读他在证人席上所说内容的法庭记录。嗯，它给了你，就像我说的，继续下去的灵感，无论你经历什么情况，只要你坚持不懈，你就能成功。你记得自己在审判时说过这话吗？是的，我记得。
One man said letters from the angel saved him from alcoholism and thoughts of suicide. Jesse testified, too. This is him reading a court transcript of what he said on the stand. Well, it gave you, like I said, inspiration to continue, no matter what the circumstances that you were going through, that if you persevered, you could make it. Do you remember saying this at the trial? Yes, I do.
你会说你仍然坚持你在审判时说过的话吗？是的。你会说你仍然坚持你在审判时说过的话吗？啊，是的。所以事情是这样的，杰西，你知道的，唐·洛里骗了你，多年来一直代表别人给你写信，你与这个给你写信的女人建立了情感联系，而与此同时你出现在审判现场，实质上是在为唐·洛里辩护，我正试图理解你是如何以及为什么要这么做的。嗯，就像我以前说过的那样，其实不是为他辩护，而是帕梅拉才是我们所有人把注意力转向去帮助她的那个人，这意味着也要帮助唐。我理解唐其实是整个行动的幕后主策划，但当她出现在这些会议上，并且表现得好像她就是信中那个帕梅拉时，她难道不是在对你撒谎吗？嗯，我想你可以这么认为，是的。你曾经这么想过吗？我知道，直到现在以及这一切被重新翻出来之前都没有。
Would you say that you still stand by what you said at trial? Yes. Would you say that you still stand by what you said at trial? Ah yes. So here's the thing Jesse, you know, Don Lowry lied to you and sent you letters on behalf of someone else for many years and you formed an emotional connection with this woman who was writing to you when at the same time you showed up at trial to essentially defend Don Lowry and I'm trying to understand how and why you did that Well like I said before it wasn't actually defending him, but it was actually Pamela that was the one that we were all We turned our attention to help her and that meant helping Don also when everything I her and that meant helping Dawn also and everything. I understand that Dawn was really the mastermind of the operation, but when she showed up at
唐和帕梅拉都被判定有罪。帕梅拉在监狱里服刑两年。唐入狱十年。当我遇到唐时，我问他是否觉得自己做了什么错事。我想我做了一件非常错误的事。
these meetings and she presented herself as the same Pamela who was the Pamela and the letters, wasn't she lying to you? Well, I guess you could think about that that way, yes. Did you ever think about it that way? I know, not until now and everything, where all of this has been re-broad out and everything. Don and Pamela were both found guilty. Pamela served two years in prison. Don was in prison for ten years. When I met Don, I asked him whether he felt he did anything wrong. I think I did something very wrong.
我想我把它弄得太真实了。我确实这么做了。我把它弄得太真实了。杰西现在和他的狗丘巴卡独自生活。他60多岁了，依然单身。他最近有一些糖尿病并发症，脚趾被截肢了一部分。这并不容易。我的制作人斯蒂芬妮·傅去他在德克萨斯州的家中探望了他。
I suppose I made it a little bit too real. I did. I made it too real. Jesse lives alone now with his dog, Chubaka. He's in his 60s and is still single. He's had some complications from diabetes recently and had parts of his foot amputated. It hasn't been easy. My producer Stephanie Foo visited him at his house in Texas.
我截肢后在医院里用膝行代步车四处走动。说，你还能做到。坚持下去等等。所以，还记得你对我说过的话吗。振作起来。所以，我照做了等等，并坚持下去。哇。即使在现在，即使在今天。
I was in the hospital after my amputation running around on my knee scooter. Said, you can still do this. Keep going and everything. So, remember those words you told me. Get on your feet. So, I do that and everything and keep going. Wow. Even now, even today.
即使在今天等等。所以，但基本上那句话，你知道，“振作起来”。是谁写的其实并不重要。不。你想想，但它勾起了对过去的美好回忆，你可以活到上百岁或者更老，我希望我的心智以后也能这样保持下去。杰西还保留着帕梅拉送给他的那个小木制灯塔，它放在他卧室的梳妆台上。
Even today and everything and stuff. So, but basically that line, you know, get on your feet. It doesn't really matter who wrote it. No. You think back, but it brings back fun memories of way back when and you could be in your hundreds and everything or older and I hope to have this I'm a mind on down the line and everything and stuff so Jesse still has the little wooden lighthouse Pamela sent him it's on his dresser in his bedroom
即使在今天以及各种事情。所以，基本上那句台词，你知道的，站起来。是谁写的其实并不重要。不。你想想看，但这勾起了很久以前的美好回忆，而且你可能已经上百岁了甚至更老，我希望将来我也有这样的心智，所以杰西仍然留着帕梅拉送给他的那个小木制灯塔，它放在他卧室的梳妆台上。
and he still has two photos of Pamela and his Dan, one on the wall, one on his desk. In one, she's sitting in an office chair, hands in her lap, not glamorous or sexy or anything. Jessie says, she's just sitting there being herself. It's just a little something to say. I made a friend. Thanks this week to the many people in this American life and NPR who helped put the story together, Ira Glass, Brian Reed, Joel Lovell, Matt Turnie, Neil Drumming and Robin Semion. Also Anne Gudenkopf, Karamolka Galison, Maggie Pennman and the NPR library. A special shout-out to Stephanie Foo. Officially she was the producer of the story.
他的墙上和桌上依然放着两张帕梅拉和他的丹的照片。其中一张里，她坐在办公椅上，双手放在膝上，既不迷人也不性感。杰西说，她就只是坐在那里做自己。这只是一种小小的表达，仿佛在说：我交到了一个朋友。感谢本周为这个故事付出努力的《This American Life》和NPR的许多同仁，包括艾拉·格拉斯、布赖恩·里德、乔尔·洛维尔、马特·特尼、尼尔·德拉明和罗宾·瑟米恩。还要感谢安·古登科普夫、卡拉莫尔卡·加利森、玛吉·彭曼以及NPR资料馆。特别要感谢斯蒂芬妮·富。官方身份上，她是这个故事的制作人。
Unefficiently, I think of her as a force of nature. I'm Shankar Vidantan and this is NPR. Thanks for listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Chris Bender of One of the producers here. The Democratic National Convention in Philadelphia is going to be all over the news this week. But if the news is just too much to keep up with, don't.
低效地说，我认为她是一股自然之力。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦，这里是NPR。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是克里斯·本德，这里的制作人之一。在费城举行的民主党全国代表大会本周将充斥各大新闻。但如果新闻实在太多看不过来，那就别看了。
You just have to keep up with the Empire Politics podcast. The Empire team will be at the conventions doing quick daily episodes, first thing every morning. You get to know what's happening and what it all means without that cable news hangover. Subscribe to the MPR Politics podcast at npr.org slash podcasts or on the MPR1 app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你只需要关注《Empire Politics》播客。帝国团队将在大会现场制作简短的每日节目，每天清晨推出。让你无需承受有线电视新闻带来的宿醉感，就能了解正在发生的事情及其全部含义。请在 npr.org/podcasts 或 NPR1 应用程序上订阅 MPR Politics 播客。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。